great it's great to be here and thanks
to the organizers for inviting me here
so I'm going to talk about high
throughput technologies in cancer
research and touch a little bit on
synthetic biology at the end as a form
of measurement as well so information
flow in the sale so we were all taught
this sort of dogma when we were in high
school and since then or even then we
understood a lot more about other layers
that exist in this flow of information
in the same there's RNA that regulates
other types of RNA as well as itself
there is RNA that we now know regulates
DNA and how it functions within this
flow of information in the cell there is
of course PPI there is also interaction
between proteins and nucleic acids of
both types also proteins have
modifications that sit on them such as
glycosylation or phosphorylation that
affect the way by which they operate in
the same DNA also has more difficult i'm
sorry RNA has changes to RNA as well and
DNA also has modifications such as
methylation that determined part of how
it operates in the cell so to understand
how cells operate in any context whether
it's disease and health or whether it's
any other context we would like to
understand as much as possible of these
different layers of this actual
molecular flow of information in the set
so I will try to exemplify that by
talking about two cases of jointly
analyzing data sets that come from two
different levels of this molecular
picture of the cell as well as
demonstrate a use of synthetic
oligonucleotides in studying aspects
of regulation basically of transcription
factors acting on DNA and affecting
transcription okay so as I said I will
start with joint analysis I will talk
about using micro RNAs and jointly
analyzing micrornas and mrna as well as
analyzing glycomics data together with
expression profiling but before going
there I will show an old microarray
example here that also speaks to the
different aspects of regulation in the
cell and how the same disease can be
actually can happen as it can be driven
by different changes in the genome if
you will in this case so this is
comparing expression profiles of Brock
awan mutants to expression profiles of
rock awan wild-type patients are using a
very old version of agilent microarrays
this is from 2002 and as you can see
there's a very nice difference between
the expression profile of the mutants
and the wild-type but there is one
sample here that you want to move to the
other side okay so this one is a is a
wild-type but it clearly belongs in the
other side in terms of its expression
pattern so of course we observe that at
the time as well and went back and
genotype the patient and she was indeed
bracha one wild type however she was a
not saying that there oh yeah I'm not
saying that so however what is happening
for this patient is that the promoter of
rock awan is hypermethylated so the
bracha one protein is completely
functional if it were to be expressed
that because of the hypermethylation it
is not expressed and therefore the the
manifestation in terms of the
transcription profile for this patient
is the same as a nun functional and
non-functional bracha one okay
and it turns out as shown in later
studies such as this paper from Chuck
Peru that are the this phenomenon that
we saw as an anecdote if you will in
this early study is much more prevalent
and in fact forty-three percent of
triple-negative cases have
hypermethylated bracha one promoters and
this has an association with survival
okay so now we're going to move to micro
Renee this is a study that we did in
collaboration with annalisa Boris and
Dallas group at the radium hospital in
Oslo are covering a hundred breast
cancer tumor samples we did matched
micro RNA m and mrna and agilent micro
arrays and we are going to talk about
the joint analysis of this before going
to joint analysis of course we also
looked at a differential expression for
the microarray micrornas themselves ok
this is micro RNA 29 and this is a
phenotypic measurement that we do on the
tumors are extracellular matrix density
these are this is extracellular matrix
density one means that the extracellular
matrix is less dense in these patients
and this is for where the extracellular
matrix is denser okay so we can see that
there is well I'm not showing that there
is because I didn't show you the
statistics but believe me there is a cig
statistically significant differential
expression of micrornas between ECM for
and ECM one the top player here is mere
29 okay so it sort of is differentially
expressed between dense extracellular
matrix and not so dense extracellular
matrix mere 29 was shown to be active in
cardiovascular disease for example this
paper from ever vonage that showed that
mere 29 regulates up inhibits collagen
and therefore leads to less fibrosis
less cardiac fibrosis in mice in this
case
this is a paper from field South lab at
Stanford that shows that inhibition of
mere 29 reduces cases of Arctic aneurysm
Arctic is one of the arteries leading to
the heart aneurysm in mice as well so
mere 29 is related to the elasticity of
blood vessels okay which is very
consistent with what we saw about
extracellular matrix density but the
fact that it's consistent that's not
enough we want to know is this really
the case that mere 29 is directly
affecting the extracellular matrix or is
that an indirect effect of mere 29 or
maybe some sort of a passenger effect
that we're looking in with respect to
this here so to answer this question
what we do is we take the so this is
here this is the hundred patients in the
cohort and I ordered them according to
the level of expression of mere 29
that's the top panel here okay now
remember i also have mrna data in this
for the same cohort for the same people
so now i take all the genes in my mrna
measurement and i rank them according to
anti correlation to this pattern of mere
29 expression ok so the top gene here is
anti-correlated to this lesson tie
correlated etcetera etcetera I'm only
showing the top of course because we
have tens of thousands of genes okay so
I rank the genes according to anti
correlation and i'm going to ask our
mere twenty nine targets enriched at the
top at the top of this list so are the
targets of mere 29 really down regulated
as the level of mere 29 expression
increases and therefore we see a direct
action of mere 29 and its targets in the
tumors
so I know that to answer that are mere
29 targets and rich at the top of this
list we're using statistics that we
called minimum hypergeometric I'm going
to briefly describe that I even though
due to time limitations are I will not
go into the details of the ideas as
follows I have I ranked I ranked my
jeans according to anti correlation to
mere 29 that was the first step and then
some of these jeans are targets of mere
29 and someone are not the ones are the
targets of mere 29 and the zeros are not
so I get a binary vector and ordered
binary vector as a result of this
ranking and assigning a one or a zero
whether it's a target or not okay now I
I look through all possible thresholds
in this binary vectors and at each
threshold I count the number of ones
that appear above this threshold and
compute the hypergeometric p value for
that event that's it easy to do and then
I will take for all these possible
thresholds the minimum observed
hypergeometric given of course during
this trick involves multiple testing and
this number that I get here is this
minimum is not really a p-value okay I
can correct it or I can also run a
dynamic programming process that
actually computes the actual p-value
assuming that I randomly and uniformly
draw this vector of zeros and ones ok so
again I don't have time to go into that
part but we can compute an exact p-value
for the event of observing this
enrichment of ones at the top of the
vector so having done that on this mere
29 date I remember that's where we
started we get the answer yes of course
otherwise I wouldn't be showing it here
that in the the targets of mere 29 are
enriched in this set and with the p
value that is significant okay we can
also look in using the same approach at
what functional annotation is enriched
in this list of anti corollaries to mere
29 and we find that in this case it's
cell adhesion again consistent with this
ECM observation and with the
observations in cardiovascular disease
that I mention another example of that
is mere 18 again and now I will wreck
according to correlation to Mirren t18
this is there's a less obvious
mechanistic explanation here and I will
not I'm not going to look for targets
when I do the direct coral it is because
of course this is not the mechanism by
which micro RNA act and I find cell
cycle to be enriched in the qualities of
mere 18 beer 18 is a known on come here
so it makes sense that it accelerates
the cell cycle another example is mere
150 again I'll look at the correlative
and I find immune response processes to
be enriched in the genes correlated to
mere 150 mere 150 is orthogonal to the
standard molecular classification of
breast cancer that was mentioned here
this morning so it is not necessarily
highly expressed in luminal a versus
basil or anything of that sort it's
completely orthogonal to that and it has
it is associated to prognosis in our
triple negative or basal samples so the
next study are involves working with
glycan profiling I will explain what
that is in the minute or so again there
are two data sets over the same cohort
of patients like and profiling is one
data set and the other is the mRNA
expression that I mentioned before we
are used to cohorts here again from the
radium hospital and let me say what
glycan profiling is so proteins have
carbohydrates that are attached to them
they are the glycosylation of the
protein the proteins that go into the
sea room also have sugars attached to
them what we do in serum glycan
profiling is we cleave off the sugars
from the proteins in the serum and we
profile only these
sugars okay we profile them using an
hplc method where in this example here
I'm showing 1 chromatogram so every one
of these Peaks basically corresponds to
a sugar that needs it you need to
develop the method in order to to
associate with sugar it is that's
associated which of the peaks but that's
something that can be done and in this
case we developed a signature that has
or a pattern if you will that in each
chromatogram we can identify 46
different Peaks pertaining to 46
different sugar groups ok so I have for
each patient I have the mRNA expression
and I have a vector of 46 numbers if you
will of course the height of the peak
represents the abundance of that sugar
46 numbers representing the glycan
profile the serum daikin profile so this
is looking in another cohort at cancer
samples versus healthy samples this is
glycans in the serum so this is taken
from blood there is no two more involved
here ok and you can see that there is a
reasonably good it's not as good as we
see with gene expression or with
micronase but a reasonably good
separation of cancer from normal are
using the glycan the serum glycans the
top are for example the top grew sugar
group separating the two classes here is
this group 18 and this is the profile
for this particular group 18 where the
right hand side are the healthy and this
is the patients with cancer in this case
but ok so so we can measure serum
glycans and we can maybe say that they
could be potentially good biomarkers but
do we understand anything about why it
is that we're seeing lower levels of GP
18 in the cancer samples then we'll see
in the healthy samples can we say
something about some mechanism that's
happening in the tumor that is reflected
in what we're measuring in the blood so
in order to try to answer this question
we can do the same trick as we've done
with the micro RNA arm and again here
I'm going ordered the samples according
to GP another sugar group doesn't matter
GP 34 abundance ok I'm going to rank all
the genes according to anti correlation
to GP 34 and I'm going to do this ma g
trick again finding the finding and
enrichment of so the mRNA for the mRNA I
do have a notation I know that I know
more about mrna then I know about these
glycans so I'm going to use that
annotation and find which go terms are
enriched in this coral a tease to GP 34
and in this case it's a cell mobility
and then cell migration and processes
that have to do with how cells in fact
with how cancer metastasizes so and and
you know that sugars are involved in
these in these processes of of cell
mobility so by using the information
that I have about the jeans i can now
assign a meaning to levels of certain
sugar groups that i see in the blood
doesn't that depend on what the person
is just eating and timing of their
it does of course well first of all
these are not this is not glucose in the
blood right these are these are cleaved
off the proteins still it does so not
all proteins that go into the blood come
from the tumor some proteins that go
into the blood just come from whatever
there they've eaten that's true
nonetheless if I see a statistically
meaningful so I mean the people it's not
the case that all the healthy people ate
one diet and all the you know the cancer
patients had ate another diet so despite
this noise we can still extract the
signal but sure the serum glycomics is
not affected only by the cancer the
point is that the cancer affects
sufficiently much of the care of the
serum glycomics to be able to get the
signal I should say that I didn't want
to go into these details but they're
highly sialylated sugars these are the
sugars they have lots of stars on them
this has only one star but some of them
have more copies of sialic acid they are
sort of characteristics of cancer so
cancer normally has more sialylated
sugars so we actually saw this this idea
of taking one type of data and jointly
analyzing it with another type of data
where I would prefer that other type of
data the mRNA expression for that matter
to have some clearer notation is
something we encapsulated into and v's
sorry into a cytoscape plugin which is
called in this and this takes primary
data matrix as input that's the mRNA it
takes an annotation matrix that goes
with that primary data matrix so I know
something about each one of these
elements and it takes a p-word data
matrix so there are three matrices that
the user has to put as input and the
software the plug-in computes these
associations that have just shown using
that method that I've just shown and
provides all the cytoscape visualization
mechanism to go with it in order to look
at the results that you get okay
and with that I'm going to shift to
synthetic biology also moving from
reading DNA to also writing DNA so the
way by which we make microarrays at
agilent is basically using a device
which is like a printer so it prints
instead of printing RGB colors it prints
a CG NT and you can think about a
microarray is sort of uh so there are
molecules coming out of the floor and so
these are the molecules right coming out
of the floor and the first base of all
the probes and the microarray is a
picture if you will in the colors ACG NT
so I will print this picture is the
first base then of course there's
chemistry going on but then I'm coming
with the second picture second base
that's another picture another picture
another picture and this way we can grow
larger oligo nucleotides we can take
these oligonucleotides and cleave them
off of the array and then we get a
library of all ego nucleotides this can
be tens of thousands of all eager
lupillo tides and now I'm going to show
an example of what we can do with these
oligonucleotides so this is joint work
with with the run say girls lab at the
Weizmann Institute and we used an oligo
library nuclear or legal nucleotide
library in this case to study the
sequence determinants of transcription
how changes in sequence care in promoter
regions can affect transcription in
yeast how did we do that so as I said we
synthesized a library of all ego
nucleotides whereby the there's there
there are constant regions to every
nucleotide these are the purple part
here and then there's the variant region
that's the green so the green is a
promoter region that we have complete
control of the sequence of that promoter
okay
we can change the sequence content of
that promoter to be whatever it is
whatever the questions are that we want
to ask about how does this sequence that
sits here in the green effects
transcription so for example we want to
put in the core binding site we want to
not put in the core binding sites we
want to put two copies of the core
binding sites we want to maybe reverse
the core binding sites we can do all
these tricks we have as I said tens of
thousands of questions to ask and we
know exactly what question we're asking
because we're designing these variant
regions here so we aren't we synthesize
days week leave them off we put them
into plasmids which are standard
plasmids for that for that matter that
that can go into yeast and express this
yellow fluorescent protein from the
promoter that we just played with the
sequence of okay so now we have if we
had in this case we had 6565 hundred
different sequences here now we have
sixty five hundred different plasmids
everyone is driving a yfp from a
different sequence that's sitting on the
promoter region okay I want to know
which one of them does that better which
one of them in which one of them did I
manage to not get any transcription at
all which one of them did I manage to
get more transcription than the
wild-type for example okay so and then
we take these plasmids we grow them in
e.coli we put them into yeast we take
these yeast cells and we [ __ ] sort them
according to the yellow fluorescence so
I have a bin for every level of yellow
fluorescence there's a red hair ignore
it it's something has to do with
normalization just to confuse you so I'm
going to sort my yeast cells according
to our the level of yellow fluorescence
ok now I'm going to take each one of
these bins in sequence the variants that
are in there so I of course I can pull
out only the region I'm interested in
and i'm going to ask how many reads do I
see
from each one of these sequences that I
had on my original design this way I'm
going to get for each one of my variance
a profile so k is high yellow
fluorescence one is low yellow
fluorescence and I get a profile for
every variant this guy had many reads in
the low yellow fluorescence and no read
in the high yellow fluorescence while
this guy had no read in the low yellow
fluorescence and many many of its reads
in the high yellow fluorescence so I get
the profile for each one of the variance
ok from that profile i can now infer a
relationship between the variant and the
efficiency of transcription or the
efficiency by which that variant drives
the yfp which is what i was interested
so an example of that would be that we
do a scanning mutagenesis of the core
promoter of gcn4 so in my variant region
here this is where the yfp is driven and
we have two new clothes on repelling
sequences here and in between we have
the core the core binding site for gcn4
in East ok this is it this is the core
binding site and i'm going to mutate
this T to all other other three
possibilities the g2 or other three
possibilities etc then I'm also going to
use to play with double mutations and
some triple mutation of course even tens
of thousands are not sufficient to do a
lot of these ok so I have to stop
somewhere so and and what we see ok and
this this here represents if you will
the average of that profile that I said
I'm going I'm getting for every variant
so the more to the right this bar goes
the more efficient that variant is in
driving yfp now remember this riot wife
p is driven by gcn4 binding to this
supposedly assuming that nothing else is
happening here and indeed this is the
content this is the wild-type the
contents of sequence and it has some
level of of transcript
and nothing else all the other mutations
are basically interfere with that
transcription except one this one here
now but if you look very carefully at
this one here this is muting mutating
this C into a G and that's just a
reverse complement of of their consensus
so in fact what this means is that it's
either the consensus or reverse the
consensus but that's it everything else
doesn't work ok so GC and for you don't
want to mess with the transcription
factor binding site for GC and for that
might not be the case for other
transcription factors multiplicity we
can put several copies of the essays
this is again the GC and four so I have
seven places where I can put it I can
put either zero copies I can put one
copy two copies etc for three copies i
have seven choose three possibilities of
word to put them i put all of them and
then i study so every like for example
here for as I said for three I have 35
options so just the gcn4 is is the green
part so I all these efficiencies and I
see that indeed as you would imagine if
I put two of them that's more efficient
than just one of them three of them is
better but it levels off pretty much
when you go to higher numbers it doesn't
help you to crowd more and more core
binding sites for GC and four so we also
saw that for God for but that's it i
will just mention that sometimes you
know if we put them too close to each
other then they interfere with each
other so if you want to drive expression
higher in synthetic biology by using the
promoter and putting more core binders
on it you may want to be aware of how
close they are to each other okay I'll
just mention that other groups have used
illegal nucleotide libraries such as
this paper from Donna pale and Jason
jewelry that did scanning mutagenesis of
a promoter in e.coli
I'm not going to go into the results and
we also did work with three Pratt so the
idea is that using these early goals you
can sort of play with the sequence
content of different regulatory elements
I showed promoters and transcription
factor binding sites but it can be
anything it can be regulatory it can be
coding it can be splicing it can be any
kind of mechanism that you want to study
as soon as you as long as you have a way
by which to measure which of the
variants work better than others and
then that will teach you something about
the mechanism that you started so we did
we work as I said with three prime utr s
we now moved into mammalian systems and
other labs have also moved into
bacterial systems recent paper on
internal ribosomal entry sides protein
optimization of course you can play with
the coding region and see what works
better in the protein sense and we're
very interested in new ideas if you have
any so in summary I showed some
statistics in rank lists and related
tools are including joint analysis of
different molecular levels over the same
cohort glycon glycan serum glycomics is
a potential source of biomarkers and
potential source of understanding what's
going on in the tumor which is very
accessible to us because it's in the
blood and I showed some applications of
oligonucleotide libraries and thanks to
all the people that did the work and to
you for your attention
well I have an equilibration proposal
have you ever considered link our
likeness ah no yeah but I do you know
the link RNA binding sites okay good so
that so yeah what you need for that is
basically some idea of something you
want to test sequence determinants of
and some idea of how you want to design
the sequences because the advantage of
this it's not going to tend to the 14
different variants it's on the tens of
thousands that we know more or less
where we want to look so this is looking
under the lamp but it's a very big lamp
that's the idea I'm happy to talk about
that yeah we work for RNA molecules
single-stranded RNA we do not synthesize
RNA but the three prime UTR work is in
RNA so we t 7 trance transcribed them
right yeah so you transcribe using that
you may we make the DNA whoever does the
experiment transcribed the RNA and then
yes you can do RNA
I thanks / and I just have to freaking
out